fais ta prière mon
poteop vite d'Ant plus qu' sont
immobil la famille for chois fr le Pays
des Neiges pour le premières
vacan
pasop du monde votre mission est de
récupérer le microfilm repose sur ce
voyage en
famille ça risque de déclencher une
guerre entre l'Est et
l'Ouest tuz cette gamine c'est un
[Musique]
ordre serait-il possible qu' soit mêlé
d'une façon ou d'une autre cette affaire
militaire la guerre est inévitable il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour arrêter de
le sort du monde dépend de l'endroit où
atterrira ce microfilm j'ai
des nous devons affronter ça en famille
tu vas devoir faire
mieux
éliminer ti bon
j'arrive spy family
COD j'accomplirai ma mission quel qu'en
soit le
prix